I was watching the tail end of that last
when I was getting enraged at the
functional programming zealots I hate
functional programming I can argue
against it it makes no sense I mean
ultimately you're boiling down to
assembly language or machine language
right and functional language is just an
abstraction on top of it and you know if
you want to be cool and hip you can say
you love functional language but deep in
your hearts you know you don't get it
not really now I'm just not a fan uh I
work with I'd say about 10 to 20 percent
of my colleagues at Microsoft where I
work like and understand functional
programming 8090 percent of us well out
of the remainders who don't like it very
few people have the courage to say I
think functional programming sucks right
because like oh dude you know you're out
of it you know I mean like come on let's
get with the the program here but when
you reach a certain age or you know
level you think you don't care anymore
functional programming sucks end of
story
so if you're a functional programmer we
you can talk to me later about it but
you know I actually you know I get into
arguments about this it's very difficult
to articulate why I don't like it but
that's another story
we'll get started here I know that this
is the end of a long day for you so I'm
going to try to be pretty snappy here
and get done sooner rather than later by
that I mean just not go as fast as I can
but deliver information my goal is to
give you enough information to find out
if you're interested in finding out more
information and then then learning on
I'm not going to go into great detail
here in 30 minutes while we're warming
up here on raise your hand if you work
here at Microsoft like a lot ok so I
guess they'll be easier raise your hand
if you do not work at Microsoft oh wait
a minute some of you raising your both
of your hands so
what that means is most of you are being
paid by Microsoft but aren't actually
doing any actual work at Microsoft okay
yeah welcome to that club well I uh this
is a true story I speak a lot I'm a work
my name is James McAfee I work in
Microsoft Research but I'm a developer
my background is in applied mathematics
but I do a lot of speaking in part
because I'd love to say I'm a really
great speaker but I'm not I'm I'm like
okay but at Microsoft Research where I
work everybody else is so hideously bad
where was I oh I was saying so basically
I suck as a speaker apparently so bad
that I can break microphones and audio
equipment but I am a lot of lot of my
friends work in non you know technical
roles including a lot of my friends at
human resources so I they know I'm a
speaker and one time I said hey you know
I'm going to be speaking at
such-and-such an event this was two
events ago and there'll be a lot of
non-microsoft people there and I know
that we're always trying to promote
Microsoft can you give me something that
I can present or show that illustrates
what working up Microsoft is like so so
I asked them and this is no joke this is
what they sent me I'm not making this up
this is what it's like to work at
Microsoft now I know the half of you
that work there y'all going yeah that's
me right there on the end apparently you
have to be a fashion model an athletic
fashion model and have a Italian
wardrobe now I don't know about any of
you but I guarantee you I don't work
with anybody like that I mean this is
not my day-to-day working environment so
in the interest of honesty and fair play
I asked the guy who sits next to me he
has a Camry always drags it around I
asked him to take an actual
photo of me and my colleagues at work so
here's the reality now that's that's
just a joke that's not true at all but I
just had that to warm us up here mostly
I want to get across the room the point
here see is this where's my slideshow
here we go okay so welcome to swarm
optimization with Python basically the
first thing I'm going to do is sort of
motivate you know what what is the
problem involved here then I'm going to
show you what I consider to be the three
hello worlds of swarm optimization
amoeba method particle swarm and
simulated bee colony and then we'll wrap
it up again the idea is not for you to
become experts but free to become aware
of it and in addition to show talking a
little bit about the technical son I'm
going to talk about why these things
aren't used and try to give you some
insights are these things practical are
they just some sort of like wacky
research kind of things and we'll see so
classical numerical optimization how
dare that last speaker use linear
regression no because I was going to use
it so presumably you recognize well not
you said I'm sure you're all aware of it
well maybe or not you know maybe you're
here so this top equation is a linear
regression and the idea is to predict a
credit limit of some kind it's made it
up based on a person's age annual income
and some sort of measure of Education
okay now here's a question how do you
find those magic a zero constants
anybody know is kind of a trick question
not really I'm sorry it had a so the
common heroes it has an analytical
solution and I'll translate sometimes
called a closed-form solution or an
algebraic solution which means for a
given set of data you minimize the
squares and you can actually grind out
but the actual values that do minimize
the sum of squares now there's many ways
to do that but most of them involve
inverting a matrix okay
now that can go wrong very very wrong
now to mathematicians it's beautiful its
elegant it's solved but if you have to
actually code this up there's a lot that
can go wrong and we won't go into that
but trust me can anyone even tell me one
thing that can go wrong with matrix
inversion or scratch that
when is matrix inversion not even a for
you I'm sorry a non-singular okay there
are certain matrices that aren't
invertible okay
yeah but Oh non square okay well yes
you're right but also even with square
ones there are ones that are not
invertible anybody else well I'm sorry
latter condition numbers that soared the
same idea what I was trying to get at is
a really immense matrix okay large data
anyway bottom line even though the first
one has been studied since I don't even
know when it's not always feasible to
solve now what about the second one what
is that equation an example of sorry I
can hear a sigmoid function yeah that is
correct but more I mean there's a more
common term for it yeah several of you
logistic regression and basically we're
trying to predict a binary thing sex
male or female number line that would be
that would give me fired for sure
walking down that path where it's sort
of the same idea where you feed it some
inputs x magic variables and outcomes a
number what is the result of this
equation no matter what age and bees are
if you use that pad
earn the y-variable will be what between
zero and one and so therefore less than
0.5 is one sex and greater than 0.5 is
the other now what about finding the B
values for this one is there a
closed-form analytical algebraic
solution to this anyone know raise your
hand if you think yes there is you know
if you think No
and that leaves 99% of you who are too
tired to raise your hands okay it turns
out there is no closed-form solution to
this so you have to do an estimation of
some kind and these are I mean there's a
whole bunch of other things that are
like this neural networks you go on
anytime you have an equation based
prediction system you're going to have
to estimate magic constants and what's
going on here is many of these
techniques are based on gradient descent
now we could talk forever about this but
a weight value a weight is just one of
the magic numbers and there will be a
difference okay this is one of those B
values and for any value of the B
there's going to be a different error
okay and obviously you want to find the
value of the weight that does what now
finds the minimum error and you can see
that it's right here so what's the
problem I mean this is calculus right
find the middle the problem is you don't
know what this blue line function is the
only thing you can see is one snapshot
of it at a time the little dot and if
you know that dot you can compute a
partial derivative which is sometimes
called a gradient that hat is like a
slope you can like up there it's a
positive slope which means that at
weight 7 the slope is positive we want
to go down and so forth now can't I mean
beautiful brilliant elegant can this go
wrong in a lot of ways how far do you go
down if you sneak down a little bit at a
time you're going to go like what
happens over here you can get stuck
there's all kinds of things so this is
one or these are some of the scenarios
that are the motivation for thinking
about swarm intelligence okay now I'm
going to so that was sort of the
motivation part here's the the three
hello world so I'm going to start with
what's called it has three different
names amoeba method optimization or
simplex optimization or nulled or mead
optimization there's other names too but
amoeba method sounds the coolest so
that's why we use it we imagined that oh
by the way this one dates from about
1965 and it's not normally considered
it's not called swarm intelligence but
it really is it has all the
characteristics the idea here is that
we're imagining that a possible solution
is like an array or in two dimensions
you can visualize it and the red dot
represents the correct answer somehow in
simplex Optima does anyone notice
simplex is what do you say to anybody
else yeah a simplex is a triangle okay
more or less so that's why they call it
a triangle what you do is in amoeba
methods is a optimization you take three
potential solutions now if there's three
of them at any given point one of them
will be the best solution one will be
the worst and one will be the other you
know now why is the best one they're
labeled best why is it best because it's
closest and the worst one is worst
now the ameba method optimization so in
other words instead of one solution at
any given time you have multiple
solutions and in this case they're the
points and here's my harness my vast
power point skills and nu if you iterate
you'll you'll see something like this
boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom and done you've captured it so
that's why it's called amoeba method
it's sort of when you graph it in two
dimensions it resembles kind of an
amoeba crawling around and engulfing its
prey which is the solution now what's
going on there so in terms of an
algorithm you initialize three points
simplex so there's the swarm idea when
you have multiple solutions you have a
swarm then you loop this is very you
know all these swarm things have some
kind of a loop usually called an epoch
now this thing let me go to the next one
and before I leave this slide
it's called simplex optimization because
it's a simplex and there none of these
swarm techniques are actual algorithms
they're all meta heuristics which is
just a fancy way to say it's not a
prescription that you can directly
translate to code it's just a set of
paradigms that you have to implement
yourself and this is one of their big
weaknesses because no two people are
going to necessarily come up with the
exact same algorithm implementation of
many of these things but here's kind of
how it works at any given point and
we're imagining here on this one that
the optimal solutions down here
somewhere so that's the best point
there's the worst actually okay and
there's the other what you do is you
first using the other and the best
compute what's the centroid
what's an easier centroids pretty fancy
what's a better term sorry
starts with a yawn average it's just a
geometrical average you had a question
comment the question was how do you
assign the best or worst points so does
anyone want to take a stab it's it's not
calculus based none of all these swarm
methods are very simple and they don't
use calculus for the most part its
Euclidean distance you just measure you
just have
some way and this generalizes to more
than two space and you can use whatever
other measure of air you want yeah
you're going to have to really shout cuz
it
okay so sort of rolling back here with
optimization is going well wait a minute
how do I know what's best worse than
other you know I mean if I know which
one is the best I already know what the
answer is okay in all of these systems
you have training data training data is
some set of data that has known answers
okay and you're measuring error using
the training data SAP kind of makes
sense okay so I probably should have
made that clear
anyway compute the centroid then
geometrically using the worst point
through the centroid you have three
candidates in yellow to replace the
worst one and then you iterate and then
at some point sometimes though there's
like a little detail maybe none of those
yellow points is better so what do you
do you can't just get stuck so you can
also shrink remember in the little
animation when it's the ameba surrounded
it starts shrinking in on it okay so
this all sounds pretty cool and it's
actually pretty brilliant does anyone
know some of the downsides of simplex
I've got I I'm guessing that most of you
probably haven't heard of it or used it
simplex optimization it's easy to code
it's brilliant anyone want to know
what's wrong with it
sorry local optima in other words it
gets trapped a little hill we'll talk
about that one yes most of these methods
are susceptible but that's true about
all these things the main drive this
sound I'm not trying to be funny here
and this one the main thing about
simplex up it just doesn't work a lot of
times it just fails because of it
depends heavily on initialization where
you're three points start from and stuff
like that so in 1965 this
was sort of a hint of the swarm
optimization but then it kind of like
malice didn't really work for it and
then swarm optimization kind of went
away for about twenty years and there's
a little screenshot at the end I'm going
to appoint you to source code for the
three demos so that you can look at it
yourself and actually run it it's all
very simple so here's kind of what it
looks like
we're trying to up here at the top when
you're looking at these or any kind of
optimization algorithms there's a set of
benchmarks benchmark functions that you
can use to see they have known known
solutions and does anyone know what the
sphere function is well it's just like a
bowl okay now here I'm showing that
simplex can solve in iterative matter it
the the thing is it has its looking for
all zeros and it gets there pretty close
the problem is almost anything solves
the sphere function so I point this out
like if you see someone trying to
convince you about a great algorithm and
they're showing it on the sphere
function don't buy it but this is where
you always start because if your
algorithm can't solve the sphere
function it's not going to solve
anything
okay here's number two this particle
swarm optimization was it came into
being roughly 1997 or so sometimes it's
hard to pin these things down exactly
and instead of having just three points
you have a whole bunch of points the
more the better and each point is just
called a particle instead of the corner
of a simplex and it again I'm for me you
know I can only understand stuff
entirely when I see data structures and
codes so here is the data structure for
the source code that I'll point you to
so this
presents one particle each particle has
a position which is just a potential
solution and if you're a developer just
think it's an array and if you're
mathematician just think it's you know
point in n space or whatever but it also
has a velocity a velocity is a value
that indicates where the particle will
move to next okay and it's almost too
simple so for that particle where will
it end up next in the next iteration
it's at three one point five five where
that is it'll be next at I'm waiting for
someone to say the answers to two three
everybody get it you just add I mean
there's nothing magic about it
simplicity and each particle has a
measure of error okay at its current
position and it also has memory
unlike the simplex method that has no
memory each point is has no memory each
particle has a memory of the best
position it found and the Associated
error in addition the over the
collection of all particles there's a
global overall best position found by
any particle and its associated okay
kind of get that you can sometimes it's
hard to get what depends everybody's
kind of different some people you know
like take functional programming and
good programming
he can't retaliate he's not here
I hope he's not here you're going to get
shank me on the way out okay
here's kind of what the algorithm looks
like or not not kind of what this is I
pulled this code snippet from the demo
so you can see exactly what it looks
like and basically you can see there's a
while loop and then you process each
particle and what's interesting here is
the key
at each iteration you calculate a new
velocity okay the new velocity will
determine where that where that point
goes next and the new velocity to pet
has three components where the first
thing is called the inertia a particle
that's moving tends to keep moving in
the same direction that's good okay but
it also has a component that tends to
move it towards the best position it
ever found okay and it also has a third
component that moves it towards the best
position found by any particle in the
swarm yeah I kind of get that Oh
what's up what's the one thing that that
if you were asked if you're a skeptic
raise your hand if you're skeptic just
in general good I like cranky skeptics
who out there you don't even have to be
a skeptic what's here I'd be gone whoa
whoa whoa whoa wait just a minute hold
everything what's suspicious about this
code ah
yes louder well good well first of all
it is the weights see these weights
these magic cut where the heck did these
come from you just go whoa do these whoo
you know here's some magic numbers well
it turns out that jumping ahead to the
end every numerical optimization
algorithm I aware of has parameters that
you have to tune you know I mean
gradient has its parameters and small
optimization has parameters too okay and
most algorithms are incredibly sensitive
to these choice of values in other words
you use some magic values and poof
things wonderful unicorns rainbows use
you just change a little bit and boom
you know you're done one of the things
that's interesting
in particle swarm optimization seems to
be highly resistant or robust in the
sense that those numbers have some
theoretical foundation but changing them
it seems to work
you know with the regardless of those
numbers compared to has anyone ever used
neural networks
oh wow quite a few of you and you know
the learning rate and momentum I mean
it'll drive you crazy you change it like
by 0.001 you know either
remarkably good or remarkably bad things
happen these are more robust or so it
seems when you I couldn't harness my
skills but when you graph things this it
sort of has this thing so this just has
actually ran this and logged the results
I took just two of the particles a red
one and a blue one and they initially
start out at random locations and then
at each iteration they move subject to
three influences what happens is this
sort of has this weird spiral thing you
know and as you know swoops in and
quickly they usually converges pretty
quickly this is we're talking about
these benchmarks I'm watching at
benchmark functions and has anyone heard
of restrictions function before this is
the one of the roughly twelve functions
that everyone in the field you know I
was a university professor before I
started working at Microsoft and we used
to have to go to these faculty parties
so I'd hang out with all the math guys
yeah we were a real fun group but there
was a group that was even worse what
department what department think about
God the most boring and yet
simultaneously annoying people
yes accounting department huh I swear it
was almost like a rumble every time the
math guys in the accounting guys you
know who but it never went that far but
anyway you know they'd be sitting there
and they have all their cultural things
you know like the English department
they be talking Shakespeare math geeks
like me we'd be talking weird stuff and
accounting guys no one would pay
attention them but in numerical
optimization these benchmark functions
are kind of like the cultural
information
that lets you talk the talk and
restrictions function you can see it's
kind of hard to see what's going on here
but you can see that this one's really
hard because of getting things trapped
I'm not sure that you can tell it is but
it's kind of like a zoo into these
little things there's only one Optima at
Sur look right in the middle so it's a
very tough problem and here is the demo
code that you can run yourself and it
shows sort of again the same thing here
we've got 50 particles okay what's
what's better about more particles well
why don't you just have a million
particles more particles the better
because they're going to they're going
to be scattered out more or they're
going to find things faster or they take
the back they're going to find things
more accurately I just gave it away
performance you know you always got to
worry about performance trade-off of how
many particles and processing time
anyway but there's a looping thing here
and you can see that even after all a
very very quickly it swooped in on rest
Riggins function pretty well it didn't
find that one it didn't get into that
one Valley I guess I'll say it here
because sometimes people ask that in
these swarm things a common technique
that I didn't implement in the demos is
having particles die off okay where they
have a certain lifespan you can see that
some particle just going to get trapped
but after so many epochs or iterations
you just kill it off till one off kill
off low performers and then give birth
to new one at a random location so this
birth death process is almost it usually
are often very helpful and I pulled this
up just to give you an idea of what the
code looks like only because you know
like what I'm saying
I don't I hate it I hope none of your
talks had some speaker go up I just pull
code up and start going through a line
at a time just go how did you know I can
read code later I you know I need you to
explain code to me but I just want to
get but it is useful I do like to at
least see
you know okay give me a rough idea and
you know what the most important part of
this code is well two things a notepad
if I can't code something in notepad I
don't get it I'm totally serious you
know I have to be able to do a
technology notepad does anyone like see
what's it see uh WCF Microsoft WCF
windows communication foundation you out
yeah I mean nothing is the spawn of
Satan you know means like who what evil
what evilness created such a monstrosity
of a technology there's only one thing
where's a sharepoint you know it's like
ridiculous I hate that thing HTML anyway
sorry the important thing here is
notepad to get across the fact that
these swarm things are simple and also
over here the scrollbar in gray which
gives you an idea there's not I mean
these things are relatively small you
know it's short and simple okay one last
one then we'll wrap things up here make
sure we get out of here quick the third
one is simulate a bee colony
optimization now it is entirely
different one thing I'm not okay the
main difference here is for swarm
optimization they fall into two buckets
one is numerical optimization where the
goal is to come up with a set of type
double so to speak or floating points or
numbers with decimal points the other
kind of combinatorial algorithms okay
they're entirely different but when
you're reading it about this stuff that
they'll just launch right in and not
tell you whether this is a numerical or
a combinatorial thing they're entirely
different the simulated bees where each
bee represents a potential solution is a
combinatorial thing it is quite
remarkable basically we've got a bunch
of bees and it simulates the behavior of
honeybees you go oh come on really no
really
so you've got three kinds of bees you've
got the the worker bees who go from the
hive and seek they know where to go
right they've got this memory they go
there and then they will examine a
flower next to where they're at again if
it's a better flower they'll go there
then they come back and they keep doing
this I actually contacted some
researchers at University of California
Davis that are the world-famous B guys
these guys love their bees I mean they
they know everything about bees I asked
you how long do they live how far do
they fly you know what is the percentage
of different kinds of bees they told me
all this stuff and they really helped me
out anyway you've got the worker bees
then you've got the Scout bees what do
you suppose they do
Scout yeah brilliant what does that
person work at Google ha oh sorry
while they go out and randomly explore
so you know you simulate that you that
sort of simulates the birth death and
then there's also inactive bees and
waggle you know the waggle dance how
wait I probably shouldn't have done that
it's kind of disturbing the bees will
transfer information among each other
this one I'm not going to go into it's a
little bit more detailed explanation of
the algorithm it's a more complicated
algorithm but I had to show you that I
harnessed I I took Latin in high school
APIs whatever it is APIs is B in Latin I
knew you'd be impressed
now the unlike the benchmark numerical
optimization problems which use
restrictions and grist Chunkin sphere
and all this the standard benchmark
problem for a combinatorial problem is
the Traveling Salesman probe problem so
you've got a bunch of cities on a map
and they're connected in some ways and
the distance between any two cities you
know it can vary and the goal is to
visit every city exactly once in the
shortest distance possible and so here
you know using the the factorial there
is a even for only 20 cities which is
like you just look at you know I could I
could have thrown up 20 dots on the
screen to go there can't be that many
possible well there are and if you go up
to 100
it's a number that is beyond human
comprehension you know more than the
estimated number of atoms in the
observable universe that's a lot so
anyway the point is the Traveling
Salesman problem is really hard
combinatorial price and you're not going
to get it just by guessing and here is
the oh this one I'm actually going to do
a real-time demo season of beam so this
is a real-time demo of the code that
I'll point you to saw attempting to
solve the Traveling Salesman problem see
it doesn't proceed entirely smoothly and
poof and in fact in that amount of time
running on a pretty crappy Dell laptop
it's found the optimal path which was
set up in this way trust me I wasn't
faking that yeah yeah I wouldn't put it
past me though okay so we're on the home
stretch here sort of wrapping up
so just because this is intended to give
you an overview of the field the the
three things that I consider the the
basic swarm things are the simplex
because it has historical interest and
you should know about it
particle swarm because it's probably the
most mainstream and simulated bee colony
because it's a combinatorial algorithm
but there's other ones that you might
run into in fact hundreds one of the
problems with this is like if it swims
flies crawls creeps or metabolizes
somebody somewhere has made a swarm
optimization algorithm after it you know
you name it it's out there and that's
actually I mean I'm not joking you can
find there's a Wikipedia page that lists
all of and it just goes on and on
simulated aardvark
you know optimization now genetic
algorithms I put up there because you
probably heard of it they're normally
not considered swarm methods even though
they have most of the characteristics of
swarm they normally they normally don't
fall into that bucket but there are
numerical optimization they're out of
favor right now because they have very
slow convergence because they generally
work with binary arithmetic which means
things are really slow there is this
thing called ant colony optimization in
my in the field of swarm and
optimization these guys are like the
zealots they're like the functional
programmers of programmers they're like
ant colony optimization it does
everything you know I mean they really
believe in ant colony optimization but
it was designed by some wacky PhD
student who wasn't very smart I don't
know and it is is it solves you know the
Traveling Salesman problem you know
searching for a path through a graph and
that's all it does but people have tried
to apply to other things so that's you
know part of the deal here is like many
of these techniques are general but some
of them are very specific like ant
calling bacterial foraging is a sort of
an example of an exotic numerical
optimization kind of like super fancy
particle swarm relatively new one that's
kind of interesting is Firefly our you
know
flies have this glow thing but they
model the bioluminescence and how you
know like the brightness of a light
varies according to square of the
distance and they do kind of stuff like
that but what's interesting about it is
unlike some of the others is it's
multimodal by that a problem suppose
you've got a problem like you know graph
where there's four equally low points
you throw a bunch of the simulated
fireflies at it and they automatically
self-organize and find all four it's
quite remarkable
now you might go wow that's really
impressive and it is impressive
sadly multimodal optimization problems
aren't very important you know like who
cares you know I mean it sounds cool but
it's not really all that practical
I also added simulated annealing is
another method based on physical stuff
but it's not a swarm technique so not
everything is swarm ok last slide so you
got a the main thing as swarm
intelligence characterized by a bunch of
things each of which represents solution
there's no need to use swarm when normal
methods work
ok and but normal methods don't always
work so they're not guaranteed in most
cases to find optimal solutions but
that's true of almost anything medicare
ristic this is a big deal it's not a
prescription you can get this idea of
modeling bees but then there's like lots
of different variations one thing python
was not for swarm intelligence with
Python wasn't part of the discussion
until relatively recently because these
things take more processing power and
Python used to be too slow now what's a
Python it was the hardware but now that
hardware is caught up you know Python it
like you saw in real time is very
feasible now here's the psychology the
whole thing I work at Microsoft Research
does anybody from else from research
here today I know there was a few
speakers well even if they were here
they went ray
their hand because they wouldn't want to
be associated with knowing me my
colleagues basically hate me for many
reasons you know personality and I mean
everything else but they also because I
like these things but that the official
research community generally looks down
on swarm techniques for several reasons
first of all in research I worked in
academia and its publisher parish you
know that's still very true and you
can't really publish a paper in a
reputable journal unless you throw Greek
letters and prove lemmas and theorems
and do all kinds of fancy proofs where
swarm intelligence is more like discrete
mathematics and you can't really prove
stuff which I agree is bad
and but a lot of research say well
forget it we're not even going to look
at it most of my colleagues I can you
not refuse to even consider it okay but
so there is this thing that you should
be aware of you know it has a bad
reputation in the old school but younger
people and more forward-looking
companies and things like that
especially with the rise of large data
these things had a large data very well
and they can be they can really work
well I'll leave this slide up here you
can take a picture of it or you can
write to me I'm JM MC of Microsoft comm
but basically if you switch for particle
swarm using Python simplex using Python
similarly be using Python I posted the
source code on my blog site and it
should be easy to find I'm going to go
away from the slide for a second but
I'll be right back
that's it thank you